[Aplausos]
[Música]
os voy a hacer una pregunta qué pasaría
si un día ronald reagan resucitará de la
tumba y se encontrara con donald trump
se harían amigos o no tendrían las
mismas ideas los mismos valores os puede
parecer una pregunta un poco tonta pero
creedme no lo es
[Música]
veréis tanto ronald reagan como donald
trump están considerados como iconos de
la derecha estadounidense verdad los dos
son algo así como el hombre del saco de
la izquierda y bueno los dos han hecho
una carrera en el mundo del cine o de la
televisión sin embargo aquí es donde
terminan los parecidos la tarea de
reagan no era otra que sacar al país de
una de las mayores crisis económicas de
su historia y para eso inició la llamada
revolución conservadora
[Música]
una doctrina económica basada en bajar
los impuestos reducir el gasto público y
las regulaciones a reagan le gustaba el
capitalismo y el libre mercado más que a
un tonto un lapicero y en la parte
personal
reagan aparecía como un hombre sencillo
humilde y campechano o algo así como una
figura paternal para todos los
estadounidenses un hombre de profundas
convicciones morales
de skate
donald trump es todo lo contrario si
algo le gusta a este hombre es presumir
de sus millones de dólares el lujo y una
esposa que podría ser su niña
[Música]
en otras palabras que si reagan era el
padre de la nación
trump es algo así como el tío el clásico
tío que todavía vive en su apartamento
de soltero tiene una cuenta en kinder y
se emborracha en las cenas de nochebuena
y qué me decís de las ideas políticas
trump no es precisamente el mejor amigo
del libre mercado ni del gobierno
limitado todo lo contrario si algo le
gusta a este hombre es poner barreras al
comercio y proteger la economía del
mercado exterior al menos en teoría la
política de trump sería lo opuesto a los
valores tradicionales del partido
republicano vaina
en otras palabras que este partido está
pasando ahora mismo por una de sus
mayores batallas ideológicas por un lado
tenemos a esos republicanos que
defienden los impuestos bajos el
gobierno limitado y los valores
conservadores y por el otro tenemos a
esos republicanos que se acuestan con
actrices de cine para adultos ponen
aranceles al comercio internacional y
son amigos de vladimir putin
[Música]
y os preguntaréis quién está ganando
esta batalla pues creo que ya os podéis
imaginar la respuesta hay una oleada de
republicanos que están dejando el
congreso con tantas diferencias
ideológicas hay toda una generación de
políticos republicanos de la vieja
escuela que están dejando el parlamento
queréis un ejemplo pues quedaos con este
nombre paul ryan o ryan era el portavoz
de los republicanos en el congreso
durante años este hombre se convirtió en
el guardián de las esencias republicanas
quería reducir el gasto público y
defendía un gobierno muy pequeño en un
libre mercado sin restricciones
paul ryan ya ha dicho que no se va a
presentar a las elecciones legislativas
y muchos compañeros de partido están
haciendo lo mismo pero esperad un
momento porque esto no es todo el
problema no son los que salen sino los
que entran y aquí tenéis el ejemplo de
alabama el candidato al senado que
apoyaba trump roy moore fue acusado de
abuso de menores durante la campaña
electoral
después de este escándalo los
republicanos perdieron en alabama por
primera vez en décadas pero lo más
sorprendente de todo es el hecho de que
todo un presidente de los eeuu apoyará a
un supuesto depredador sexual os
imagináis algo así hace sólo cinco años
como es lógico este escándalo en alabama
salió en todos los periódicos nacionales
y salpicó de lleno a la casablanca y os
preguntaréis qué hizo donald trump para
solventar esta crisis de comunicación
[Música]
exacto nada no hicieron nada y eso
explica que ahora mismo haya tantos
candidatos republicanos que están
cayendo en las encuestas a pesar de
presentarse en estados tradicionalmente
conservadores pero todo esto que
significa para la casa blanca pues bien
como sabéis este año hay elecciones
legislativas las llamadas maternas que
es donde se eligen a los miembros del
congreso y a buena parte
de los miembros del senado
en eeuu el presidente es decir el poder
ejecutivo se vota en unas elecciones y
el poder legislativo se vota en otras
elecciones totalmente distintas eso
explica que por ejemplo aunque obama
fuera un presidente demócrata la mayoría
en las cámaras legislativas fuera
republicana pues bien en este caso según
muestran las encuestas es bastante
probable que la mayor parte de los
candidatos republicanos pierdan es decir
que donald trump va a tener bastantes
problemas para poder sacar cualquier ley
con un parlamento y un senado en su
contra
pero la pregunta la auténtica pregunta
es cómo ha llegado el partido
republicano hasta este punto como hemos
pasado del reaganismo al trump ismo en
tan poco tiempo puede un partido cambiar
de principios tan rápido hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la revolución reagan seguro que muchos
no lo sabéis pero ronald reagan empezó
su carrera política en el partido
demócrata tal cual como lo oís sin
embargo en el año 1962 cambio de ideas y
de partido
pero esperad un momento porque el
partido republicano que se encontró
ronald reagan era muy distinto al que
todos conocemos según reagan los
republicanos habían terminado por
comprar casi todos los principios de los
demócratas y seamos honestos en parte
tenía bastante razón si lleváis tiempo
suscritos a visual político ya sabéis
que a mí me encanta hablar de hegemonía
cultural de hecho tengo un libro escrito
sobre este tema la hegemonía cultural es
un concepto muy marxista y a la vez muy
útil para entender la política
básicamente consiste en todos esos
valores que crea la élite dominante para
justificar su relación de poder
es un consenso que comparten
prácticamente todos los actores
políticos incluido el partido de la
oposición pues bien en aquella época en
los años 60 ese consenso era el estado
del bienestar y la necesidad de un
control del estado sobre la economía de
hecho tanto nixon como eisenhower que
eran presidentes republicanos pasaron
por la casa blanca sin apenas tocar la
economía y como os podéis imaginar
reagan no era precisamente un fan de
esta hegemonía política esto que vais a
oír ahora mismo es un fragmento del
discurso tiempo de decidir los que seáis
muy forofos de la política
estadounidense seguro que ya lo conocéis
alguna nación en la historia ha
sobrevivido a una presión fiscal que
alcanzó un tercio de los ingresos
nacionales y aquí viene la parte
interesante la hegemonía cultural es
algo que se puede cambiar como pues bien
cuando todos esos valores y esas
doctrinas ya no sirven para
una crisis la gente pierde la fe en el
sistema y eso es exactamente lo que pasó
en los años 70 cuando eeuu se enfrentó a
una de sus mayores crisis económicas y
esa crisis fue la ventana de oportunidad
para que ronald reagan pudiera
reinventar el partido republicano y
crear un nuevo corpus ideológico que es
lo que ahora llamamos conservadurismo
en otras palabras reagan creó su propia
ideología
[Música]
ahora os preguntaréis cómo se puede
crear una ideología cómo se crea un
discurso político de la nada que tenga
sentido y que te permita ganar unas
elecciones pues muy sencillo reagan se
dirigió a todos esos grupos que de
alguna forma se sentían apartados por el
mainstream político se dirigió por un
lado a la derecha religiosa por otro
lado se dirigió a los militares y
finalmente se acercó a todos aquellos
que querían impuestos más bajos después
reunió a todos estos grupos bajo un
mismo concepto que es lo que llamamos el
significante vacío
[Música]
un significante vacío es una palabra con
un significado muy genérico para que nos
entendamos el significante mansilla es
algo así como una letra de héroes del
silencio alguien sabe lo que significa
no y precisamente por eso todos
proyectamos el significado que queremos
que tenga para algunos maldito duende
puede ser una canción de amor para otros
una canción protesta pues bien en el
caso de ronald reagan el significante
vacío era la libertad y que es la
libertad pues para un conservador fiscal
libertad es un estado pequeño con
impuestos bajos pero para un neocon
libertad es luchar contra los dictadores
entendéis por donde voy verdad
en esta crisis el gobierno no puede
solucionar el problema el problema es el
gobierno sin embargo hay un problema
cómo es posible que juntemos en un mismo
sitio a gente tan distinta pensadlo bien
un señor que quiere reducir el tamaño
del estado no se puede llevar muy bien
con otro señor que quiere incremento
el gasto público para tener un ejército
más grande verdad pues mis queridos
amigos de visual política la clave para
crear una identidad política que
funcione es tener un antagonista y en el
caso de reagan encontrarme enemigo era
pan comido o pan de skate
[Aplausos]
wow
[Música]
exacto los malvados comunistas y eso
explica que en los años 80 tengamos
tantísimas películas donde los
comunistas son los malos ahí tenemos
amanecer rojo rock y 4 y por supuesto
top rank y aquí tengo que hacer un
paréntesis 'top gun' es un peliculón
si tenéis la oportunidad de verla no os
la perdáis porque de verdad es una
película para fidel paréntesis el caso
es que con estas películas junto con los
discursos de reagan se construyó una
nueva hegemonía política de hecho
incluso bill clinton que era demócrata
tuvo que prometer más bajadas de
impuestos para ganar las elecciones
[Música]
sin embargo como ya sabéis en los años
90 la unión soviética desaparece ya no
quedan malvados comunistas contra los
que luchar y qué pasa cuando te quedas
sin un antagonista que dé sentido a tu
identidad política
puedes utilizar otro tras el 11 de
septiembre el presidente republicano
george bush anunció una nueva batalla
entre el bien y el mal la lucha contra
el yihadismo de repente el 'tío sam'
tenía un nuevo enemigo
llevaremos nuestra causa por todo el
mundo con nuestro trabajo y nuestro
coraje no descansaremos no nos
retiraremos y no fracasaremos ojo por
supuesto que no estoy diciendo que los
terroristas no sean malos ni muchísimo
menos que los crear a eeuu vale lo que
estoy diciendo es que se pueden utilizar
como un elemento retórico para crear una
identidad política y lo han hecho
prácticamente todos los grandes
presidentes
roosevelt reagan y tantos otros
políticos de todo el mundo
[Música]
sin embargo qué pasa cuando la unión
soviética ya ha caído y bin laden ha
muerto llega el momento de un nuevo
discurso político llega el momento de
todo
[Música]
la revolución de trump tras la crisis
financiera de 2008 la doctrina
hegemónica se pone otra vez en cuestión
de repente la gente vuelve a no confiar
en el sistema
la palabra no se difundió entre los
medios de masas y la pregunta que surgió
era si esa falta de cobertura mediática
era porque no era noticiable o porque la
gente contra la que protestaba moss
tenía el control de casi todos los
medios de masas cuando los votantes
pierden la fe en algo se crea un vacío
un vacío que alguien puede llenar con un
nuevo discurso y aquí es donde entra el
señor donald trump de nuevo tenemos a un
candidato presidencial que se alió con
toda clase de grupos políticos y
religiosos que se sentían apartados del
mainstream para que os hagáis una idea
el 80% de los cristianos evangélicos
votaron por trump mucho más que ningún
otro grupo religioso sin embargo los
valores evangélicos de familia y moral
la antítesis de los divorcios y los
escándalos sexuales de trump y es más
incluso después del escándalo de stormy
daniels que es una ex actriz porno a la
que trump supuestamente pago para
comprar su silencio el 78% de los
evangélicos siguen apoyando al
presidente es más algunos líderes
evangélicos han ido aún más lejos y han
llegado a decir cosas como esta
si los conservadores evangélicos le
damos una oportunidad para que se redima
dijeron te permitimos que empieces de
nuevo y tengamos una segunda oportunidad
tony perkins hablando en la cnn pero
como se explica este fervor exacto por
la figura del antagonista es decir para
donald trump el enemigo son los medios
tradicionales los de las fake news y por
supuesto lo que se llama el pantano es
decir todos los políticos de washington
y bueno por supuesto hay un tercer
enemigo que todos conocéis los
inmigrantes más exactamente los que
estéis viendo este vídeo que habláis
español en otras palabras que trump
tiene el recurso fácil de decir o yo o
ellos y en ese sentido su retórica no
decepciona
de los violadores mexicanos a los bad
hombres la campaña de trump en dos
momentos y sigue esta retórica le está
funcionando también a trump los demás
candidatos republicanos quieren imitar
la todos quieren apelar a esa base de
votantes y por eso muchos presumen de
ser más tranquis tass que el propio
trump queréis un ejemplo pues aquí
tenéis el anuncio de uno de los
candidatos a las primarias republicanas
de virginia
el capitán del pantano mitch mcconnell
ha creado millones de trabajos para los
chinos y con eso
mitch se ha hecho rico y la pregunta es
funcionará este cambio de ideas en los
republicanos muchos analistas creen que
no y por el momento el partido
republicano está perdiendo un montón de
dinero en donaciones de hecho hay 40
candidatos republicanos que ya han sido
superados en lo que a dinero respecta
por sus contrincantes demócratas
no está
[Música]
los republicanos están perdiendo en la
guerra de donaciones para las
legislativas de 2018 con gente como paul
ryan fuera muchas empresas han dejado de
dar dinero al partido antes el comité
central republicano podía ayudar a sus
candidatos para que financiaran sus
campañas ahora muchos de ellos tendrán
que pagarse los anuncios con su propio
bolsillo sin embargo siempre decimos en
visual político no se pueden hacer
predicciones en política así que ahora
es vuestro turno creéis que los
republicanos están perdiendo
credibilidad creéis que perderán votos
frente a los demócratas
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a visual
político para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto